nous allons
j'évoque devant et quand j'avais 6 ans
avec un copain qui est accoudé chez moi
on allait chercher le nouveau voisin qui
l'envy demandé si je voulais bien bien
avec nous et nous sommes emballés et je
crois qu'ils étaient contents qu'on
vienne le chercher juste publié à peine
arrivé dans le quartier super morgan et
je crois que nous aussi on était très
content de pouvoir élargir la bande et
c'est comme ça que comme tous les gamins
de trage on a constitué une bande de
copains avec pour occupation principale
sur l'autre une heure trente pour jouer
dehors des sentiers alors au fur et à
mesure des années et les copains qui
rejoint la bande d'autres qui ont dit de
partir et vivre et on a constitué comme
ça une grande énergie et vainqueur plus
tard reste c'était à environ sept ans on
était maintenant des étudiants gelé dans
des villes
un petit peu éloigné l'on prenait un
certain plaisir à se retrouver à
continuer à jouer dehors ce que matin se
mouiller tout à fait dire la même chose
ça veut dire des petits voyages et ses
parties toujours comme ça en fait elle
garde parce qu'on gagne pas à faire un
voyage en cadets à conserver alors que
vous ne connaissez rien et fut rédacteur
un jour l'organe est arrivé avec cette
idée nous a dit les gars c'est pas une
idée que j'ai c'est un projet de le
faire trois ans 54 me km entendu
tous les continents je pars dans deux
ans quand on gagne un peu d'argent et
pourra le faire que si vous voulez
comprendre les sept premiers ensembles
vous pouvez alors je vous cache pas
qu'au début moi j'avais tendance à me
retrouver dans la situation inverse de
départ finalement c'est moi ont été
chercher pour aller une joue edward même
si ça voulait plus du public en bonne
forme et vous savez pas faire moins
le voyage aux îles c'est un truc qui me
paraissait un petit peu trop gros trop
froid impressionnant ça faisait peur
donc ça me demandait de sortir un petit
peu de moi même de penser au delà de mes
propres limites
élargir une période de penser en reste
que ça me demandais je vais dépenser
avec en fait avec les autres puisqu'on
était maintenant trois cas à s'être
engagés dans ce projet là et que
certains concédé par thierry donc ce que
je voudrais partager avec vous ce soir
c'est sam c'est la propension parfois
que certaines amitiés auront à
s'immiscer dans la vie et finalement à
nous lancer des défis pour ce serait
déjà bien lancé tout seul et il sortir
du lot booting qui serait presque trop
facile à lire donc de voici deux ans
plus tard un vélo jusqu'à sa gueule
partout un duvet chacun dans 3 ou 4 ans
et 4 et surtout la ferme volonté de
continuer à jouer
bon maintenant ça veut dire parcourir le
monde à la force des jambes
sauf que on n'est pas seul puisque
l'humain c'est tout le crédit nous le
vélo c'est vraiment un truc c'est un
outil pour pouvoir découvrir la langue
et on avait anticipé que barclays en
trois ans 3 ans et maintenant que c'est
quand même assez loin
kapil km au 6 mai l'idée c'était en fait
cet état d'esprit qui nous réunit c'est
ne faisait pas de se lancer des petits
défis il fallait qu'il persiste dans ce
grand projet qui arrive à 3 donc l'idée
c'était vraiment se lancer des défis
empereur donc commençons directement
allant dans le vif du sujet par exemple
traverser l'avenue 2500 km sur une piste
dont connaissez rien vu en fait très peu
d'informations sur cet endroit on a
commencé à se frotter un peu les vues
satellites s'apercevoir de village il
allait falloir 400 kilomètres peut-être
au maximum
regardez pas ce qu'étaient les cours
d'eau pour pouvoir leur habitat y en a
et puis en fait on s'est aperçu c'est
commencer à être envisageable qu'un
produit létal
on a parcouru ce que ces pistes la
transamazonienne l'anglais dans la norme
olivier et un an plus tôt au brésil et
c'était vraiment l'étape la plus
difficile de la fois physiquement
parlant parce qu'il est extrêmement
chaud 40 45 degrés c'est presque 100 ans
en humidité à certains moments getty les
deux par jour par personne
un décès ces cours d'eau et le soir moi
je me rappelle un peu peur dans mon mac
du monde ça le rhône sartini brésilien
savoir et ville et les locaux les
habitants où vous effrayer les histoires
déjà voir disons oui des pasdarans bon
en réalité elle est là tandis que ça
l'est ce que je vous dis à travers ce
défi là c'est que en fait ce quotidien
qu'on l'avait choisie n'est pas du tout
confortable mais en fait c'était quelque
chose qui nous souder au jour le jour
parce que ensemble pour le décider tiens
de chaque jour jour après jour donc
trois ans à se lancer des défis de ce
genre là mais aussi trois ans à vivre
ensemble
même si au québec donc il a fallu qu'on
apprenne à se parer imaginer 54 mille
kilomètres roulent ensemble tous les
jours on mange matt hamill d'histoire
ensemble on partage la même tente on
découvre des visages on s'en rend compte
des personnes sont en fait on est tous
ensemble
parfois il ya des choses qu'on fait par
regards sur et tout ça pour vous dire
que la volée apprendre à parler ensemble
si on est des amis d'enfance il connaît
très bien sait beaucoup des plaies on
vit dans le contexte de maintenant aux
états unis ça fait un an et demi qu'on
roule on a un petit peu ma radio que
vous m'aidiez on n'est pas des cyclistes
et j'avais lu un livre tant aventuriers
qui avait défendu le choix du yukon dans
sa gamme et je vais proposer l'idée aux
copains je leur dis pourquoi pas prendre
du placard et mettre des vélos de danse
est basé sur la musique populaire jeu
proposé l'idée un organe il trouvait ça
chouette etienne il trouvé que c'était
une très bonne idée et il avait commencé
à lire en fête du béret si peter
thompson et dee mais n'en fait plus que
plaisir en radeau le chercheur d'or à
lui si on allait arriver bientôt
et si pas exhiber pourquoi s'arrêter à
12h06 la ville me cherche encore
s'arrêter
eh bien pourquoi ce qu'on n'irait pas
jusqu'au détroit de béring en mer
arctique est vrai que la surenchère
comme ça peut paraître un petit peu a
forcé
et en fait le temps parce que cette
synergie qu'ont développée en gros elles
étaient plutôt positives et c'est vrai
que si on m'avait dit un jour qu'elle
soit conforme à d'autres aussi pour
descendre le belge aurait absolument pas
cru d'accord mais pourtant on a commencé
à réfléchir ensemble et ça c'est fait
donc nous voici sur les 20 carats de nos
propres mains avec l'aide d'un d'amuser
charpentier qu'il a rencontrés sur la
route est au début et il ne faut pas
qu'on me proposait de défaire ce radeau
je faisais mais tout ça c'est plus mon
idée que je descende en canoë j'ai une
empathie citer aussi j'estime que moi
pour paris est en réalité cette
lisibilité et d aller dans les deux sens
c'est pas parce que je suis initiateur
du goûter ou d'un projet que je mets le
seul décideur et puis je discute de tout
ce que l'équipe de recherche ou encore
et c'est perdu la vie dans ce projet là
c'est qu'effectivement la créativité en
groupe c'est observées et proposé mais
c'est aussi savoir accueillir le regard
de l'autre sur sa peau
je me plonge dans sa tête comme va le
sous sol très simple très content que
vous puissiez écume au courage mais donc
c'est aussi aller au bout du au bout du
problème
donc moi sur ma diction voilà les dites
moi je trouve ça complètement fou alors
pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça
finalement
c'est pour vous dire est ce que on
pourrait pas porter un autre regard sur
notre amitié est ce qu'on pourra se dire
[Musique]
ok certes on va avoir un coût enfin on
dîne ensemble éventuellement part en
vacances ensemble mais l'amitié vécu
jusqu'au bout qu'est ce que ça pourrait
être pour nous c'était un engagement en
temps on discutait aussi au liban qui
est en fait aujourd'hui on a tendance à
avoir une amitié comme ça que je vois
qu'ils se séparent alors moi je peux
comprendre non plus que ça donc j'ai
parlé de nous parce que je pouvais pas
parler d'autres exemples jeu par exemple
prenez dans le bonheur
maria steve jobs s'il bosse bien c'est
de bonne ou pas qui partagent un couple
bidules électroniques les tirs ensemble
avec un peu d'audace et les capacités de
chacun bien utilisé créer son ordinateur
sur le plan d'eau du seigneur sait tous
que ça que c'est devenu comme on peut
tout dire du mal la réussite commerciale
est extraordinaire
ensuite il ya un autre exemple j'aime
bien vite dans le domaine social ou
politique en coin thelma et louise deux
héroïnes d'un film sont deux femmes qui
sont gestionnaires combat contre le
patriarcat et finalement il ya elle fuit
le mari visage misogyne complètement de
l'une d'entre elles et elles sont rares
dans un road movie complètement
rocambolesque et à la fin elle désirait
de résidence même la vie on est désolé
j'étais spoiler le film ils vont jusque
là et moi pour moi tous ces exemples là
il veut le dire vraiment l'amitié vécu
jusqu'au donc je vous pose sur moi je te
préviens bien les grandes idées dans
contente d'un petit peu de philosophie
de vie s'échauffent une idole pour
attendre les garçons et on avait avec
d'autres éditeurs et écrit un livre sur
notre premier grand voyage autour du
monde et il arrive collection qui était
intéressante qui pouvait prêter à un
rallye sur l'amitié
on a commencé à travailler ça ensemble
et donc j'ai acheté une pile de livres
on commence pas très grande ça fait déjà
pas mal j'ai commencé à lire son sujet
ce que nous sommes aperçus finalement
c'est le rapport qui existe et qu'il
peut pas du tout évident que moi pas
entre amitié et démocratie nous explique
christophe anquetil actes élémentaires
démocratique c'est quoi assez parlé
ensemble un dialogue libre 104 ap
égalitaire aussi mais en vue d'une
action qui va dans le sens de l'intérêt
commun intérêts communs on a défini au
préalable l'ensemble et qui peut à tout
moment à être modifiées donc en fait
démocratique et sociale
ce processus vertueux enfin le mot
république
l'étymologie c'est res publica la cause
politique donc la cause publique
défendues d'une fatigue
alors moi lisez c'est vraiment lent rain
ou sur votre oracle voudrait en fait
c'est exactement ce qu'on faisait mais
dans notre petit micro peut nous aider à
nous de jouer droit et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre culture
occidentale moderne en alternance avoir
un métier comme les temps quelque chose
de l'ordre de l'intimé domaine rider et
on comprend par exemple la montre
l'annoncé que je souhaite aussi que tout
le monde connaît mais qui est instit
institutionnalisée dans le domaine
public par le mariage n'a rien
d'équivalent pour le l'amitié on va voir
le bien de nos jours les cieux
comme ça dans l'amitié publiquement ça
veut dire quoi
aristote 10,1 au sens le plus noble du
terme ça veut dire être un acteur de
l'année aura donc pour nous ça voulait
dire grave et démontre ait traversé des
déserts des jeunes alignés sur 20 km par
jour
et c'est vrai que quand on raconte
comment pendant longtemps raconte le
voyage on
et moi j'avais effectivement c'est une
très bonne école pour apprendre à vivre
ensemble
mais c'est pas dans le sens j'ai réussi
à supporter mais mode pendant trois ans
du coup je reviens plus tolérant dans la
vie normale c'est finalement ça s'est un
petit peu de se dire est ce qu'on
pourrait pas voir ce genre d'aventuré
aussi l'apprentissage du plat certaines
vestes et un respect qui veut dire en
fait dans l'autre barge les coudes avant
de juger
et vous le dis pourquoi pas il a
peut-être une bonne idée
les directs avec mon idée est de la
défense donc c'est pourquoi il veut pas
dire oui pour faire plaisir à l'autre il
veut pas dire non donc la gonfler ce
qu'on est vôtre est il simplement de
jacques caraës ce je crois pas il est
archi le soin des possibles en fait sous
la piscine et durant toute cette
aventure c'est vraiment ça que moi j'ai
appris quand on perd
et si je pouvais vous laisse avec
quelque chose ce soir ce serait
peut-être un peu de consistance et dans
cette pro de proverbes africains qui je
crois est connu par beaucoup de monde
qui dit tout seul on va plus vite
ensemble on va plus grands vins donc je
vais pas vous laisser maintenant parce
que j'ai des copains qui m'attendent
pour les vaudois remercie moral
[Applaudissements]